closing arguments in the derrick chauvin
trial will begin on monday the former
minneapolis police officer chose
not to testify on his own behalf under
the fifth amendment
this is after testimony from dozens of
prosecution witnesses
and a much smaller number for the
defense jamie yukas has more on the
story from minneapolis
i will invoke my fifth amendment
privilege today for the first time since
the trial began
derek shovin spoke in court while the
jury was not present
you feel that your decision not to
testify is a voluntary one on your
behalf
yes it is it was chauvin's decision to
not take the stand in his own defense
the defense rested joe tamborino is a
minneapolis criminal defense attorney
not associated with the case do you
think he maybe wanted to testify
i think he should have testified you
have to decide is this person going to
be good on the stand
many people are not then there was a
stunning development that nearly led to
a mistrial
the issue surrounded the defense expert
testimony that carbon monoxide poisoning
may have contributed to george floyd's
death
was mr floyd's blood tested for carbon
monoxide
i could not find a reference to it it
turns out the medical examiner
had tested for it the prosecution wanted
to call back a pulmonologist to present
those test results
but the judge said the testimony would
be inadmissible at this stage of the
trial
but if he even hints that there are test
results
the jury has not heard about it's going
to be a mistrial
pure and simple dr martin tobin was
allowed to testify
carbon monoxide poisoning did not
contribute to floyd's death
and with that all testimony came to an
end
now minneapolis city leaders are
stepping up security in preparation for
the chauvin verdict
which could come as early as next week
national guard troops are already
stationed in downtown minneapolis
and barriers were placed near the
courthouse and the streets surrounding
it
mayor jacob fry acknowledges with the
chauvin trial happening
so close to where donte wright was
killed the trauma of the community
is palpable
[Music]
the mayor says the city put in several
months of preparation and will be
flexible and adaptable when it comes to
protests
by using state patrol deputies and other
agencies
anthony jamie thank you